foreign
[Music]
for Friday March 17th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
imagine you're a hiring manager looking
to fill an open position and every cover
letter resume and writing test comes
back with exactly the skills you need
for the candidates
maybe it's a super talented hiring pool
or maybe it's chat GPT
teachers school districts and
universities have been worried about
cheating since chat GPT was released now
companies have concerns about Job
applicants too with me to discuss that
is wsj personal Tech reporter Anne
Muriel Cantera hi Anne-Marie thanks for
joining me thanks for having me as
always Zoe I want to start with the job
applicants who are the people who are
using chat GPT for their applications
yes some of the people who are using
Chachi PT for their job application help
include you know someone who's looking
for a new job because of all the layoffs
that are happening as well as someone
who's just like moving careers and so
they're using chat GPT to tweak their
resumes help them prep for interview
questions and also get them through
writer's block when you're writing that
cover letter that you know supposed to
wow the recruiter or hiring manager can
you tell us about one of the people that
you spoke to how did they use chat GPT
in their application process yes so
Brian Stringham who is a 31 year old who
lives in Utah he was looking for a new
job in product management he used Chachi
PT to help him get better at interview
questions tweak his cover letter but he
didn't tell anyone that he was using it
when he was applying for roles and even
the job that he has since landed they
have no idea that he is Chachi PT but he
did tell me you know he obviously had to
Ace the interviews on his own and edit
the cover letter himself so it wasn't
like Chachi BT did everything for him he
still had to prove himself so how easy
is it to write say a cover letter or a
resume using this because having tried
it myself I'm sure some listeners have
tried it out you're just asking kind of
one question or another so how do you
get it to give you a polished looking
response for a hiring manager so based
on the conversations I had with people
for this story you really need to train
and work with Chachi PT to make your
cover letter or resume sound and look
amazing you have to feed it your
existing resume a new skills you might
have acquired or in the process of
requiring and you also need to feed it
the job description that you're applying
for so you kind of feed chat GPT all
this information and then you can start
asking it like write me a sentence that
describes my skills in writing and my
skills in Photoshop what about from the
side of the people doing the hiring you
know first off how are they spotting
that some of these applicants are using
chat GPT is there a way to tell so one
employee I spoke to who works at the
company databento she's the CEO she told
me she came across five applications and
they all sounded similar and so she put
her uh writing test for the company into
chat GPT and got the same answer and she
was like well this makes sense out of
curiosity how good were the tests that
she was getting back from the applicants
they were um incredible based on her
response she said you know usually this
writing test people don't always pass it
and that's fine because it's you know
about the journey not just passing the
test but this one people pass with
flying colors and that's what also made
her you know in her brain being like
what's going on here wise everyone doing
so well all of a sudden what was her
reaction and what have the reactions
been of other companies that are finding
applicants using this so she is trying
to be technology forward with it and
embrace it because she knows it's not
going to go away it's probably going to
get even worse if anything but people
using it more and more and so now like
the writing test does say you could use
chat GPT to help you with the process
but you need to put in a little more
effort to make your application stand
out and other employers are figuring out
how to allow applicants to use chat GPT
but also making sure that they're not
making the process even longer or the
test longer because then you're making
the process just worse for everyone
involved the employer the potential
employee and so it's like a it's a kind
of an existential question right now for
many employers they think of like how
much to embrace how much not to embrace
it how do they deal with it is it viewed
by applicants or by the companies as
cheating if you use chat GPT in some
cases I do believe the employers believe
it is cheating because you're
essentially assessing chat gbt and not
the applicant itself right I wonder
companies have been using AI when it
comes to looking through their stack of
potential candidates is this just
flipping the tables on that now ai is on
the side of the applicants instead of
just the companies oh absolutely yes and
it's fun to see it unfold in real time
like we just saw a new version of GPT
released recently and so we're going to
keep seeing how people figure out the
best ways to use this and game the
system when the system has been being
gamed against them I mean there have
been tools out there for a long time
that job applicants can use you know
templates from Google Docs or Microsoft
why is this so much different from
utilizing those part of the issue that
some employers are are thinking about is
if chat CPT he writes an amazing cover
letter of your skills and what you can
do is it still an accurate
representation of who you are and like
what you actually can do
because it could really vary like some
people can come up with crazy and
wonderful things to say about themselves
with the help of chat GPT but
if they can't actually do the job then
it's like well was it really helpful to
have chat gbt help you do this whereas
Google doc templates or Microsoft Office
templates those are just templates you
still have to like fill in the blanks
yourself come up with the writing you
have to do a lot more work generative AI
applications that's the new world we're
dealing with I guess that's our personal
Tech reporter Anne Muriel Cantera thanks
for joining us Anne-Marie thanks Zoe and
that's it for this week's Tech news
briefing but before we go a quick
reminder that we want to hear your
questions on generative AI want to know
more about baidu's new product chat GPT
or lenza interested to know how these AI
programs work or what they're capable of
email us a voice recording with your AI
question to tnb at wsj.com
tnb's producer is Julie Chang we had
production assistants from Zoe Culkin
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
and our executive producer is Chris
sinsley I'm your host Zoe Thomas thanks
for listening and have a great weekend
[Music]